hey i'm alex so today i'm going to be
testing and reviewing the retro pop-up
hot dog toaster by nostalgia we'll be
looking at how well it works if the food
it makes is any good
and if you should consider buying it
let's
hot diggity dog
you know in first impression i would say
it looks
pretty good says perfectly delicious hot
dogs every time bits thicker hot dog
step plump
so it looks like you can put two hot
dogs two buns
i like the diagram of the hot dogs they
got
and voila
our hot dog toaster
i mean i do like the color it's a really
beautiful red
nice it's very sleek i have to say
there's these two little oh
there's like a cage
this is a hot dog cage
so i'm assuming you put your hot dogs in
there you can lower it in
these are for the buns
all right we got a metal tong here
it's more like a uh
something you find at like home depot
i'm anticipating it'll be a little hard
to pick up anything with this this isn't
a tong
for the heat options we've just got a
dial goes from one to five it doesn't
look like you can
change the heat specific to like i want
my bun a little toastier i want my hot
dog a little toastier like you're at one
level of heat and it's going you're
going you're stuck with it oh there's a
little more action than i thought we've
got a crumb catcher
ah the crumb catcher is actually here
crumb catcher interesting so that's
probably for like any of the toasty fun
bits that fall
hot dogs and buns helpful tips
all hot dogs and buns are not the same
ah this is like some life advice
therefore you will need to adjust the
variable heat controller accordingly all
right so i'm feeling pretty good about
this i think we're ready to go time to
see if this thing is a winner
or a wiener
so we're gonna go pretty classic here
pretty standard your average hot dog
your average bun hot dogs are not a
sandwich i mean just because something
is in bread doesn't make a sandwich put
me between two pieces of bread and you
wouldn't call me sandwich we're gonna
crack open our supplies again pretty
straight forward
one hot oh
stripping
all right these are your standard
hot dogs
just gonna put them in to the hot dog
slots
just to give you a little visual
they're in their little
their cages but if you had a plumping
hot dog it'd fit in there
it's not snug as a bug and a rug and for
our bun
just open it up like so
and i'm assuming we stick it into the
half moon
oh
these are very standard hot dog buns i
didn't get like a thick hot dog bun this
is a normal hot dog bun
and
it's a little
it's snug in there
it's tight
it's tight it's like
already like kind of squishing the bun
too much they should have like
gave in the hot dogs a little less room
and then like the buns a little more
room i think i'm gonna start off cooking
these at like a three i feel like that's
kind of like a middle ground heat
i also i'm a little worried about
uh the buns because they're so like
close to the heat that maybe
a five will just get really hot all
right i guess we're good to go
let's
oh
okay only
only the hot dog went down
should i just push him in
i guess i'm pushing him in oh i'm
smelling some smoke stuff
so
i hear
it god it smells in there you
immediately hear like the toaster going
the sound of like the earth
and i can definitely see the uh red
coils heating up it's definitely hot
right away like i feel it's pretty hot
in there so it's definitely toasting i
hear a little sizzling
oh
all right
something popped
i i guess i'm gonna check it out
oh
maybe i'll use the tongs this is maybe
where the tongs come in
it's warm to the touch
like they don't look toasted at all the
buns
it's a sad toasted bun i have to say
not only is it like ripping apart
because it was so squished in there but
it literally just burnt the edges
and didn't like it's like lightly
toasted in the middles oh and it's
breaking i'm not happy
this is not perfect every time i've
already been lied to
bad first impression
so the buns are not great let's take a
closer look at the hot dog
yeah i mean it's warm but it's like
lukewarm like i was kind of excited to
get like a little char on a hot dog like
you know i don't know this is basically
just heated through so i think the move
to make is crank it up to a five
i am looking for a toastier bun a
toaster hot dog and i think i'm just
going to have to accept that the edges
of the bun are going to burn before we
get started on our second attempt i just
want to check out the crumb catcher to
see what's going on in there
as anticipated we got a little bit of
hot dog juice a little bit of crumbs in
there definitely
some
it did the job i think that's the part
of this whole thing that worked the best
actually
is the crumb catcher
all right we're gonna try this again but
this time we're going full blast i'm
gonna turn this up to a five i'm really
going for that classic summer cookout
hot dog
the nostalgia factor that this thing is
named after
round two
hot dogs going in
straight forward see maybe they can
just squish them in
that's all you can do
next one
trying to be gentle so they don't rip
again okay crank it up to a five
all right
moment of truth
[Music]
again
just push them down
yeah and again like you can see because
it's like this half moon shape
the edges of the buns are what's
touching the metal plates whereas the
middle of the buns
are pretty far from it so it makes sense
that the edges of the buns are burning
like there's really just no way
that was almost like a volcanic eruption
my god i'm nervous
i don't want to put my face too close
you get like a hot dog facial steam at
least it's like doing something more oh
they're moving around they're steaming
up
they're like
oh
again
the thing definitely popped but it's
stuck so it doesn't pop up all the way
i'm just gonna
give it some help
oh my god
all right
yeah
so that's what was moving in there
they've got like some splits
no char or anything but definitely looks
a little toastier these buns
okay there
it's really stuck in there
okay
uh yeah same old like
even with the five toast it's like just
the edges got even more burnt
and the middle is like exactly the same
maybe i need the tongs at this point
the tongs suck
tongs don't even work all right same old
with this bun i just ripped it even more
all right well we have one that's
passable
i think this hot dog was our winner of
course you can't eat your hot dog
without a condiment i'm gonna recreate
what the box did a little mustard
squiggle on here
oh already messed that up
[Music]
i mean the bun was so fragile because it
took a real beating in that toaster
that now the bottom has ripped in half
all right so let's compare our hot dog
to the box
so i'm gonna go ahead and take a wild
guess that they did not use the
retro hot dog pop-up toaster for this
photo let's give this a try can i say
i'm that excited for it
no
it's a hot dog
i would prefer the bun to be a little
more evenly toasted
i would probably prefer even
more of a char
on the hot dog
but i'm not mad at it
[Music]
all right let's break this thing down so
function wise i would say it didn't work
quite well
i had some issues with the sizes of the
containers i think the bun slots are too
small
the tongs were just a whole other story
pop-up function was a little tricky it
didn't pop up which would have been more
satisfying and more clear whether it was
done i would say that the only good
thing was the crumb catcher which did
work pretty well definitely a stove top
or grill would have been easier even a
microwave might have worked better to be
honest if i'm gonna buy a gadget this
specific it better work so well that it
sells me to the point like i can't eat
another hot dog again
i need this toaster and sadly
this just didn't do it for me so i would
say i would not recommend buying this
and overall i'm giving it two thumbs
down all right well that's it for this
gadget if you want to see us test any
other gadgets leave them in the comments
below and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]